in Hollywood the state of a big-budget
movie can change at the drop of a hat
take 2013's World War Z for instance
after a cavalcade of behind-the-scenes
drama it's a wonder that the project
even made it to theaters but once it did
the movie proved it's worth by raking in
roughly five hundred and forty million
dollars worldwide
similarly the World War Z sequel has
changed directors screenwriters has been
assigned multiple release dates and was
even poured entirely from paramount
release calendar so what exactly is the
current state of the zombie sequel he is
everything we know about the follow-up
to world wars a Brad's back according to
variety Pitt is returning for World War
Z - given the first film's success so
that may not necessarily seem like a
surprise but it hasn't really made a
habit of appearing in sequels this time
regardless of the many projects he has
on his plate he's remained the star and
producer all along and it's a good thing
he has his hands so tightly on the reins
without Pitt leading the way World War Z
too would probably fall apart completely
mireille enos another cast member
returning is Mireille eNOS who played
Pitt's wife in the original film in a
2016 interview with Digital Spy Eno's
confirmed a return saying there's been
some shifting with directors and so the
schedules are bit up in the air but it's
definitely happening and I get to be in
there when you look at eNOS his recent
work it's clear she's been very busy in
front of the camera fortunately it
sounds like she's still committed to
making it work once what was the to
production is up and running rewrites in
2014 a year after World War Z hit
theaters The Wrap reported that
screenwriter Steven Knight was brought
on board to pen the sequel not long
after Knight delivered a draft to
Paramount Variety reported that Dennis
Kelly the creator of the UK conspiracy
thriller series utopia was hired to
deliver and rewrite the highly
anticipated sequel maybe hitting the
same type of speed bumps as the original
film but it's a good sign that the team
behind there appears to be focused on
the quality of the story
scheduling complex the film's production
schedule has definitely not been easy to
lock down in January 2017 after multiple
rewrites The Hollywood Reporter reported
paramount move to pull the project from
its release calendar this came after
multiple efforts to push back the film's
tentative release date from 2016 to a
2017 summer release according to Variety
production was once again
to late 2018 to pick could work on
Quentin Tarantino's Charles Manson
inspired film once upon a time in
Hollywood
if all goes according to plan audiences
probably won't see another World War Z
movie until 2020 and that's just a
guesstimate Finch his entrance luckily
after the major setback of losing
director J a Bayona
who moved on to direct the next Jurassic
world film David Fincher
jumped into the zombie fray according to
Variety pit has been doing his best to
persuade Fincher to take over directing
duties for some time written Fincher had
developed a solid professional
relationship over the years working
together on Fight Club 7 and The Curious
Case of Benjamin Button Fincher hasn't
directed a sequel since 1992 s alien 3
but while his addition to the project
brings high expectations his attention
to story and characters would prove a
welcome departure the director told
Collider in 2017 I don't care if the
whole scene is five pages of two people
in a car sipping coffee from paper cups
as long as there's a fascinating power
dynamic and I learned something about
them not a cash grab when Fincher
appeared on the Empire podcast to
promote mind hunter he supplied a brief
update on the sequel status explaining
their process in dissecting novelist max
Brooks his story
Fincher said we're hoping to get a piece
of material that you know a reason to
make a movie not an excuse to make a
movie this may seem like a no-brainer
but in this day and age where big budget
blockbusters focus more on jaw-dropping
action sequences and character
developmental story it's an important
detail the director further explained to
little white lies a lot of stones have
been laid we're just deconstructing it
right now against the mythology that
exists to see where we can go thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're lifting
[Music]